تكاد لا تخلو وجبه الفطور الانجليزيه من
البيض المكون الاساسي الذي اشتهرت به وجبه
الانجلش ليس فقط في بريطانيا وانما في
العالم لكن الوجبه الانجليزيه باتت هي
الاخرى مهدده مضيفه ازمه اخرى الى ملف
الازمات التي تمر بها بريطانيا فالى جانب
ارتفاع تكلفه الانتاج الناتج عن الوضع
الاقتصادي المتازم اساسا جاء انتشار
انفلونزا الطيور في المزارع البريطانيه
ليزيد المشكله حيث باتت رفوف البيض في
المتاجر شبه خاليه بعد اضرار العديد من
اصحاب مزارع الدواجن الى اعدام الدجاج
المريض
كميات للتاكد من انه في المتاجر لا يستطيع
المطعم محلي ان يشتري خمسه او عشره علب
بيض مره واحده لان ذلك يعني ان زبائن
المحل المحليين لن يحصلوا على البيض
لانفسهم
ومع تحضيرات من نقص كبير في مخزون البيض
بحلول عيد الميلاد بدات متاجر بريطانيه
مثل لذل وعزى بتقنين شراء البيض مع توجه
العديد من المتاجر الاكبر مثل تاسكو
وغيرها الى اتخاذ اجراءات مماثله
البريطانيون من جانبهم لاحظوا نقص في
البيض حيث انتشر هاشتاج النقص في البيض
على منصه التواصل الاجتماعي
بيضه واذا تم الحد من ذلك فسيكون ذلك
تحديا
الناس في الريف لديهم الدجاج الخاص بهم
هناك اشياء اخرى لاكلها ولن اتاثر كثيرا
تقول النصيحه عاده لا تضع كل البيض في سله
واحده لكن مع النقص في مخزون البيض
وارتفاع تكلفه رعايه الدواجن قد يصبح من
الحكمه ان تضع ما يتاح لك من البيض في
سلتك الشرائيه قبل ان يصبح شراء البيض
ترفا او خيارا غير متاح
عروب عبد الحق العربيه